the five-day mayday holiday is usually
one of china's busiest travel periods
but a resurgence of the coronavirus is
expected to keep people at home
authorities in beijing are tightening
covet 19 restrictions to contain an
outbreak in the city meanwhile in
shanghai residents are losing patience
after being cooped up at home for more
than a month in china's largest lockdown
the streets of beijing are supposed to
be bustling over the holiday period
residents and visitors would normally be
dining out shopping and buying tickets
to entertainment venues
but they're mostly at home
or here one of the many testing centers
meant to keep an outbreak at bay
i believe the beijing government will
not be like the shanghai government so
beijing won't suffer the same way that
shanghai did that was caused by
relaxation and prevention and control
loud pot-banging protests in shanghai
against kovid 19 restrictions that have
included bolted doors on apartment
blocks and metal fences erected to
almost shut off whole parts of the city
chinese officials maintain they have to
make hard decisions to keep a fragile
health care system from being overtaxed
china is a country with unbalanced
regional development and insufficient
medical resources
if the covet 19 response loosens to let
the virus run free
it will definitely lead to a huge number
of infections in a short period of time
and a large number of severe and fatal
cases the medical resources will run the
risk of being depleted
also at risk of depletion the resilience
of a significant part of the population
dealing with almost two and a half years
of the pandemic
maybe it's been too long everyone has
different feelings some want to go out
and have fun so maybe people's behavior
is not as consistent as it used to be
you look at a city that used to be
crowded and now is empty and you can't
help but wonder how we all managed to
survive
while there are concerns about beijing's
climbing rate of infection
shanghai's new cobit 19 infections hit a
low for the last month or so about 9 200
cases in a city of 25 million
reasonably good news for one city
offering lessons good and bad for the
rest of the country
and for more on this i'm joined by dw
correspondent fabian cutchimer in
beijing a fabian what happened might
happen next there this situation is
getting worse are people bracing for a
long-term lockdown
well i mean the worst possible outcome
would probably be the fate of shanghai i
mean if there would also be a city-wide
lockdown necessary that would drag on
for a month where even at some degree um
to some degree the food supply would
collapse um i'm quite optimistic that
this will not exactly happen but um
definitely the next weeks possibly
months in beijing also will be quite
bleak um to prevent basically a
city-wide lockdown the authorities here
have increased their covert restrictions
quite a bit uh over the weekend now um
all restaurants had to either shut down
or um i mean only take out food is um
still allowed and then basically
everywhere you go it doesn't matter if
it's a public park or if it's even a
supermarket you have to show a negative
pcr test taken within the last 48 hours
otherwise you cannot really um enter
anywhere and that is really strictly
enforced so while maybe um beijing could
prevent really a city right um lockdown
there's no really a clear answer what is
the exit uh strategy what is the
long-term game here because as someone
some
manager of a big company told me
recently um after the covet wave is
before the covet wave so we basically
live in constant fear that um a
city-wide lockdown might be imposed and
this will not really fundamentally
change because of course omicron could
pop up
anytime soon again
yeah and as we've seen in this two-plus
years of pandemic things change
countries are better or worse every
month or so but china right now seems to
be kind of the only big country in the
world that is having these massive
problems with the corona virus but why
is that
well china may be only next to north
korea also is
the only country really that sticks to
zero covet i mean even taiwan which was
also quite successfully handling the
pandemic said it will now not um
follow china's um
path in you know locking down entire
cities and will try to live with the
virus so while other countries um trying
to you know live with the virus and
gradually open up here it's basically um
still locking down sealing off isolation
border closures etc that's the strategy
and the problem is we don't have
efficient mrna vaccines the vaccination
rate among the elderly is not high
enough to really um
open up for the authorities and of
course also the leadership here is
trapped in their own propaganda rhetoric
because they can't consistently repeat
that our system is superior we can
manage and maintain zero covert while
actually in the reality the cost of zero
covet is increasing day by day
okay www's fabian catchment in beijing
thanks for that